yo what is up everybody madly g here and
today I'm gonna be talking about lock
picking and hacking in fallout 4 and how
it's similar to fallout three new dates
if you didn't know what it's like in vol
3 in New Vegas it goes something like
you need a certain amount of skill
points in lock picking or science which
is the hacking skill to be able to take
a chance at unlocking or packing certain
locks and terminals it was a very low
level lock you don't need many skill
points but for a high level lock or a
high level terminal then you're gonna
need a lot of skill points in there and
if you don't have that you're completely
barred access from the terminal or
lockpick you can see in this game play
there's a terminal to the left of me
which is hard and I just can't attempt
at accessing that terminal because I
just don't have enough levels in science
now it looks like follow for is going to
be similar to this type of lock picking
and hacking where you need to be a
certain level in the skills or the perks
of lock-picking and science or hacking
to be able to even attempt at a harder
lock or harder terminal this is a little
different than save the lock-picking in
Skyrim which has the same mechanic of
when you're actually picking the lock
except in Skyrim the various levels of
locks you are allowed to access without
having any skill points in the lock
picking skills you can access them but
it'll just be a lot lot harder and a
lower chance of unlocking the lock if
you don't have skills in the lock
picking skills so I just want to bring
this information do you guys see what
you thought about it I for one I think I
like the skyrim system more because
there's nothing barring me from
experiencing more of the game I don't
need to put a lot of points in this one
skill just have a chance and unlocking
something I can always attempt it and if
I'm good enough I've my own skill is
high enough then I'm allowed to do it so
just let me know what you guys think
about this if I'm missing some advantage
that the fallout system has over the
skyrim system let me know if I've missed
that and yeah thank you for watching be
sure to check out my channel continually
if you're into fallout 4 because it will
be posting a lot more full of for
content and as you can see on my channel
I do have a lot of fallout 4 content the
game's not even out yet so appreciate
you watching and yeah peace out